YOU BOTH FOR BEING WITH US
TODAY AND BY THE WAY, ONE OF
THE TOP PRIORITIES FOR THE
RADICAL LEFT IS TO DO
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING ABOUT THE
LOOMING CRISIS AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
DEATH, DESTRUCTION AND
DEVASTATION CAUSED BY OUR
POROUS OPEN BORDER.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
THOUSAND OF MILGS IMAGINE
THE
MIE
MIGRANTSMAKING THE JOURNEY NORTH
MIGRANTSMAKING THE JOURNEY NORT.
THEY DIDN'T TO DENY
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANOTHER
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I CAN TELL YOU THE
REPUBLICANS WANT TO HAVE A
WALL.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS SAY YOU
CAN'T DO THAT THEY ARE DOING
A TREMENDOUS DISSERVICE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE DOING A
TREMENDOUS DISSERVICE TO OUR
COUNTRY.
I DON'T THINK NANCY HAS HA
KLEE.
AND I SEE THAT WHEN SHE SAYS
WALLS ARE IMMORAL.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE -- SHE
ACCIDENT KNOW.
AND I WISH SHE DID.
BECAUSE SHE IS HURTING THIS
COUNTRY SO BADLY.
>> Judge Jeanine: JOINING US
NOW IS FREEDOM CAUCUS
CHAIRMAN MARK MEADOWS AND
THE AUTHOR OF "THE RUSSIA
HOAX" FOX NEWS LEGAL ANALYST
GREGG JARRETT.
CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS, YOU
KNOW, I HEARD SOMETHING
INTERESTING, AND THAT IS
THAT THERE IS TALK OF
BIOMETRICALLY TAGGING SOME
OF THESE ILLEGALS AND IF
THEY SEND THEM BACK, IF THEY
COME BACK, THEN THEY FACE
SOME SERIOUS PENALTIES.
ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH THAT
CONCEPT AT ALL?
>> WELL, PART OF THAT SMART
TECHNOLOGY THAT A LOT OF OUR
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT BUT REALLY THE PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE, JUDGE IS.
THIS NOT ONLY DO THEY COME
BACK BUT THEY COME BACK OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A
BORDER WALL OR BARRIER AT
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER AND SO,
LISTEN, PART OF THE SMART
TECHNOLOGY IS CERTAINLY PART
OF THE SOLUTION.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THE
BIGGER PROBLEM RIGHT NOW IS
THAT WE HAVE A BICAMERAL
BIPARTISAN CONFERENCE
SUPPOSEDLY BEEN MEETING AND
MET ONE TIME IN THE LAST
WEEK.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN HERE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. AND THEY
ARE SUPPOSEDLY COMING UP
WITH SOLUTIONS.
THEY ARE NOT SERIOUS ABOUT
NEGOTIATING.
>> Judge Jeanine: ALL RIGHT.
SO THEY HAVE THREE WEEKS.
THE PRESIDENT SAID LOOK, I'M
GIVING YOU THREE WEEKS,
GUYS.
GO IN THERE AND HAMMER
SOMETHING OUT.
YOU KNOW, BIPARTISAN, BOTH
HOUSES.
YOU ARE TELLING ME THEY MET
ONCE AND NOW THEY ARE GONE
AGAIN?
>> YEAH.
THEY ONLY MET ONE TIME.
THEY MET WEDNESDAY.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
SCHEDULED MEETINGS TO MEET
AGAIN UNTIL POSSIBLY AT THE
EARLIEST NEXT WEDNESDAY.
SO IT'S NOT REALLY SERIOUS
ABOUT COMING UP TO A
SOLUTION AND I CAN TELL YOU
WHEN THE DEMOCRATS ROLLED
OUT THEIR FIRST OFFER, IT
HAD ZERO MONEY FOR BORDER
WALL.
AND I MEAN, YOU KNOW, AT
THIS POINT YOU HAVE TO
WONDER IF THEY EVER HAD AN
INTENTION OF NEGOTIATING IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHO IS ON
THIS COMMITTEE BUT I'M GOING
TO FIND OUT AND TALK ABOUT
IT ON MY SHOW TOMORROW
NIGHT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU MEET ONCE, WHEN YOU HAVE
THREE WEEKS TO RESOLVE ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES
IN OUR COUNTRY RIGHT NOW AND
YOU PLAN ON MEETING ONCE
NEXT WEEK.
THAT'S AN OUTRAGE.
I WILL GO TO GREGG JARRETT.
ALL RIGHT, GREGG.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS THERE IS
A GOOD CHANCE AND BASED ON
WHAT WE HEARD FROM
CONGRESSMAN MARK MEADOWS,
THEY DON'T COME UP WITH
SOMETHING.
CONGRESS HAS NOT WANTED TO
COME UP WITH SOMETHING SINCE
186, THEY DON'T COME UP WITH
ANYTHING, THE PRESIDENT HAS
THE RIGHT TO DECLARE AN
EMERGENCY, RIGHT?
>> HE DOES UNDER THE
NATIONAL EMERGENCIES ACT OF
176.
CONGRESS ACTUALLY DELEGATED
UNFETTERED AUTHORITY AND
DISCRETION TO THE PRESIDENT.
THEY DID WHINE ALL THEY WANT
BUT THEY GAVE THE PRESIDENT
THAT POWER.
ONCE HE INVOKES IT, HE THEN
TURNS TO ANOTHER LAW THAT
CONGRESS PASSED SIX YEARS
AFTER THAT IN 1982 WHICH
SAYS, SPECIFICALLY, HE IS
AUTHORIZED TO UNDERTAKE
MILITARY CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS, NOT OTHERWISE
AUTHORIZED BY CONGRESS.
SO THEY GAVE HIM ANOTHER
TOOL THAT HE CAN UTILIZE
THEY CAN COMPLAIN ALL THEY
WANT AND SUE IN THE END THEY
HAVE NO LEGAL BASIS TO
PREVAIL.
>> Judge Jeanine: HE DOESN'T
NEED CONGRESS FOR.
THIS HE DOESN'T.
>> Judge Jeanine: THERE HAVE
BEEN 58 NATIONAL EMERGENCIES
DECLARED.
>> RIGHT.
>> Judge Jeanine: SINCE 1976
I BELIEVE THE LAW WAS
PASSED.
'79 WHEN THEY FIRST DID
SOMETHING.
AND ALL OF THE SUDDEN THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO DO.
THIS WE HAVE FENTANYL.
OPIOIDS, HUMAN TRAFFICKING,
SEX TRAFFICKING.
>> HUMANITARIAN CRISIS ON
TOP OF IT IF BARACK OBAMA
CAN DECLARE A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY WITH RESPECT TO
VERUNDI SOUTH SUDAN AND
SOUTH AFRICA CAN REPUBLIC,
THIS PRESIDENT CAN CERTAINLY
DECLARE AN EMERGENCY WITH
RESPECT TO MEXICO.
YOU JUST IDENTIFIED THE
ACUTE IMMINENT CRISIS
INSOFAR AS DRUGS ARE
CONCERNED 150 PEOPLE DIE A
DAY.
DOUBLED OVER THE LAST
DECADE.
THIS IS A SERIOUS EMERGENCY.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW
CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS, I
BELIEVE IT WAS JUST TODAY OR
YESTERDAY ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CATCHES OF FENTANYL COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER.
ENOUGH FENTANYL, I DON'T
KNOW IF PEOPLE REALIZE OUR
VIEWERS REALIZE THIS BUT IF
YOU INHAIL THAT STUFF, IT
CAN TAKE OUT A STATE.
JUST THE MERE PRESENCE OF
IT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE A DRUG
USER.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE A
NEEDLE NOTHING.
THE PRESENCE OF THIS STUFF
CAN KILL OFF MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE.
>> YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
EVEN OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS MANY TIMES HAVE TO
WEAR GLOVES WHEN THEY ARE
DOING A SEARCH BECAUSE IF
THEY HAPPEN TO HAVE IT AND
GET EVEN A SMALL DOSE OF
THIS AND I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT TAKING IT I'M JUST
SAYING GETTING ON THEIR SKIN
OR INHALING IT IN SOME WAY,
YOU KNOW, THEY CAN HAVE JUST
UNBELIEVABLE AND FATAL
OUTCOMES OF THAT.
SO, YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT THE DRUGS THOUGH AND
GREG IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS SOME
EXECUTIVE TOOLS IN HIS
TOOLBOX.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, WE
ALWAYS WANT TO RESTRAIN
THOSE BUT PRESIDENT BARACK
OBAMA USED IT OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
I CAN TELL YOU HE SENT
1.8 BILLION TO THE IRANIANS.
I DIDN'T APPROPRIATE THAT.
IF HE CAN DO THAT CERTAINLY
THE PRESIDENT CAN FIND A
COUPLE OF BILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT THE EFFORTS AT THE
BORDER.
>> Judge Jeanine: 1.8 BILLION
TO THE IRANIANS.
ALL RIGHT.
GREGG.
I'M GOING BACK TO YOU FOR A
SECOND.
LET'S ASSUME THAT THIS
COMMITTEE COMES UP WITH
NOTHING BECAUSE THEY WON'T
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
MEETING.
THEY ARE NOT WORKING.
THEY DON'T AIR CARE.
ALL RIGHT?
I SAY THAT FREELY.
THE PRESIDENT DECLARES A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
SOMEBODY GOES TO COURT TO
STOP IT, TO GET AN
INJUNCTION.
>> KAMALA HARRIS IS VOWING
TO DO IT.
TO DO IT AND THEN IT GOES TO
THE NINTH CIRCUIT.
>> RIGHT.
>> Judge Jeanine: HOW
QUICKLY CAN DID GO TO THE
@SUPREME COURT.
>> THE PRESIDENT COULD
PREEMPT IT ALL BY FILING
DECLARATORY RELIEF ACTION TO
GET A JUDGMENT FROM THE
FEDERAL COURT.
IF HE WAITS FOR THE NINTH
CIRCUIT AND THEY DECIDE
AGAINST HIM, WHICH WOULD BE
WRONG BY THEM BUT THEY
ALWAYS GTE IT PRONG WRONG.
>> THEY WILL.
>> HE WOULD SEEK AN
EMERGENCY POSITION.
KAMALA HASTE WAS THE STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN
CALIFORNIA, SHE SAYS THIS IS
AN ABUSE OF POWER.
CLEARLY SHE HASN'T READ THE
LAW THAT CONGRESS PASSED
GIVING THE PRESIDENT THE
AUTHORITY AND SHE IS A
MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE
AMAZING PART OF IT,
CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS, THAT
RIGHT IS WRONG AND WRONG IS
RIGHT AND IT'S ALMOST AS
THOUGH WE ARE LIVING I'M
GOING TO DATE MYSELF HERE IN
THE TWILIGHT ZONE.
IT'S LIKE WHAT THEY SAY IS
WHAT GOES OUT THERE AND THEY
BELIEVE IT.
EVEN THOUGH FACTS HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
>> WELL, YOU ARE EXACTLY
RIGHT.
AND WHEN THEY DO THAT, THEY
FORGET THAT THEY VOTED FOR
BORDER WALLS BEFORE OR
BORDER FENCING.
THEY FORGET ALL OF THAT YOU
KNOW, EACH IF SENATOR HARRIS
THINKS SHE IS GOING TO FILE
A LAWSUIT.
THERE IS SUCH A THING AS
STANDING.
I'M NOT SURE ANY MEMBER OF
CONGRESS HAS STANDING.
IT'S PROBABLY GOING TO BE
SOMEONE ELSE.
GREGG IS RIGHT, THERE IS NO
DOUBT.
THEY WILL FILE A LAWSUIT.
IF THEY CAN THEY WILL FILE
IT IN THE NINTH CIRCUIT.
HERE'S WHAT WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND.
ONE PARTY IS FOR SECURING
OUR BORDERS AND KEEPING OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE.
ANOTHER PART, THE DRAFT
PARTY IS FOR OPEN BORDERS
AND SAYING WHOEVER WANTS TO
COME IN CAN COME IN.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE